[Music]
thank you thank you
thank you
hopping on a plane and don't want to
pack then put rented clothes on your
sweaty back
Japan Airlines has tried out a new
program that gives passengers the option
of renting clothing to cut down on
baggage
the service called anywhere
anywhere
those crazy Japanese people it delivers
clothes right to a traveler's Hotel the
only requirement is low self-esteem
[Laughter]
and the outfits will come from overflow
stock and pre-owned items also known as
stuff no one else wanted
prices start at 28 bucks for five items
and come in three sizes actually Four
sizes small medium large and stelter
not sure if this includes underwear
or if like renting a car you'll not be
penalized for making skid marks
foreign
Japan Airlines hopes the plan will
reduce carbon emissions by getting rid
of excess weight in the form of luggage
unfortunately the service doesn't come
with a high line for women to call and
ask if any of the items make them look
fat
really bottom line the airline better be
clear how this new service Works
otherwise this could happen
[Music]
oh my goodness
um I'm I'm glad sir you are naked yes of
course I am I'm flying Japan air they
Supply the rental clothes for you so you
don't even have to pack
is open it's the friendly Skies it's not
a thing they don't do that oh yeah you
should try it big boy you know what
you'd save a lot of space if you just
came like me we will sit together and
have a drink God I hope not yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
Kathy actually had to edit that a little
bit
they left out a really important part of
that but anyway would you take part in
this
I feel like I would because I have so
much trouble packing but I think I would
still check a bag just full of a bunch
of other stuff right so this it's it's
almost like buying an electric car
you'll still have the other car I I
can't it is I bring so much stuff with
me I'm I I don't know what I think I
bring like every medication for every
possible ailment yeah I bring like 20
pairs of underwear for like a three days
away I don't know what I think is gonna
happen
but if it did I'd be fine yeah you'd be
the no if the plane crashed and there
were survivors you're the lady with the
underwear
no I didn't realize how bad it was
except when we went to the Patriot
Awards and one of our producers came to
my room and he was like why do you have
so much underwear you could have gotten
that you gotten that person fired that's
none of your damn business I have a rare
disease but the thing is I don't have a
rare disease not to brag
[Laughter]
how about you Katie uh you could rent up
to eight outfits for two weeks for less
than fifty dollars you travel a lot yeah
you're on the go on the go yeah I don't
know I think maybe this is better for
men than women because women are much
more specific about what they wear and
how things fit and what the sizing is
like
but I mean people might think it's kind
of weird but also if you stay in a hotel
you're basically just sleeping in a bed
that's clothing she is clothing yes
that's true you're renting that you're
just renting that bed so I don't know
the hour just depends well some of us do
that and others do not yeah that's true
you know Tyrus uh I think the only
clothing we really do rent is tuxes for
proms I don't know if I could for the
last time you did that no never mind
don't want to know
oh avoided that bear trap yeah a lot of
fans say they always say Greg will you
uh will you be my prom date I'm the only
person that says yes
I will say I've been to like 40 proms in
the last like three or four years wow
yeah I just go and sometimes I'm not
even invited
well that just like this is a stupid
idea yes uh one I'm biased because uh
even as Stout as stelter is that's one
of my legs so I know they don't have
anything for me so the hell with this
not to mention this isn't going to
change anything cat said it perfectly
she'll just pack her bag with something
else it'll just be 45 pounds of well you
don't Vape anymore but it'll be
something like that or your book
nicotine plenty of books for sales for
your shows and stuff people like to have
their little suitcases and over pack
yeah you see it every time you travel
it's like where are you going I'm going
to my grandma's for the weekend and you
needed four suitcases yeah what about
hiding there oh and they're gonna rent
clothes when I get there no this is dumb
this is just adding more stuff and how
do you know they're going to a hotel
room you know there's a lot of what have
yous and whatnot what's their favorite
color what happens there's a lot of
things that go wrong with this and then
dope and you said it's worse for women
than men no assassin it's way worse for
men because we have to sit in that damn
hotel room and go no it looks good yeah
yeah
oh
oh then we're the other one yeah like
which one is better oh so you hate this
they're all good yeah Brett you travel a
lot in the military killing people
did you uh would did you learn certain
tricks of packing because you know you
had to sneak in and out like a little
cat burglar when you were strangling
people with piano wire
no no the answer is no
um but I would definitely do this
because I'm obsessed with uh like not
having wrinkled shirts you know when you
get on the airline and like I'm always
worried about that you wear a nice suit
on the airline and like your shirt's all
wrinkled it's the worst I just I
actually just came from Poland by the
way like to this show from Krakow
um and I'm still wearing Airline clothes
I still have my socks from the airline
yeah they always kind of move though
down to below your heel they have a lot
of elastic it's happening right now to
me like as we speak but but yeah no I
I'd absolutely run who did you kill in
Krakow oh God
I kill people with kindness now okay is
that the name of your gun but
they're applauding they're the murderer
whatever they they laugh at you but if
you are trying rented clothes there's a
good chance you're gonna get someone
else's DNA yeah she's a murderer yes
like let's say not saying you did and if
you did you did what you needed to do
and I don't need to know about it but if
you did he did murder someone leaves all
his DNA then poor Gutfeld steps off you
guys are about the same size and then
to put on his suit and now that DNA is
on there all it takes is one hair I
always think about that when I'm buying
my hair yeah yes
well that's true if they're a psychotic
murderer
yeah I hope she did and then you get you
get busted for the crime that was the
joke I know
[Laughter]
but you did it way better
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else